entering Marriott's new headquarters is
like walking into a hotel you check into
the front desk grab a coffee and tap
your card to get inside where you'll
find a hotel room
well kind of we've got a little table a
bed a bench built out of foam core a
ledge built out of foam core this
mock-up room is here for testing
Flex seating areas here for
collaboration and amenities an
additional sweetener to get employees
excited to come back to the office
that's some of the things that you would
see in a hotel just kind of some of
those ingredients of bringing people
together but just done in a very
different way the 600 million dollar
space represents Marriott's bet on the
future of the physical office question
is will it draw Marriott's hybrid
Workforce back I took a tour with the
Project's leaders to find out and
discover how myriad's using the space
for work and experimentation
Marriott's new office located in
Bethesda Maryland is really a campus a
tower with 785 000 square feet of
workspace and a flagship hotel with 245
rooms including 13 that will be a little
different this particular room is going
to be a sample room for the Westin brand
so this is going to be a Sheridan room a
Moxie hotel room the courtyard room
Stephanie leonardz Marriott's president
was part of a small internal team that
helped develop the vision for the new
office in part by touring other office
spaces we went to tech companies out
west we went to other retailers to see
what they were doing I wonder were you
also drawing some inspiration from
Marriott's own properties we are experts
in hotel design we know how people are
living and working and traveling these
days and we took all of those insights
from our Core Business and put them into
this fabulous new corporate headquarters
and the hotel next door the hotel-like
design starts with the lobby it was a
way way for us to think about how do you
deconstruct what a Hospitality
experience is and then Infuse that with
a workplace and come out with a formula
that is very unique it speaks Marriott
but then it feels like you're going
somewhere different it's trying to
transport you somewhere the design does
this in one big way this video screen
how tall is it it's over 20 feet tall oh
my God and it wraps like 65 feet around
which is incredible but it also has some
more subtle knots to travel so the light
for instance is something that we
designed to queue for travel it's
literally topographic lines travel isn't
just a reference to Marriott's business
it's also how the company operates
Myriad estimates that even before the
pandemic a third of workers were on the
road
so for Jordan Goldstein and The
Architects at gunsler that meant
building in flexibility something that's
on display just off the lobby in a
three-story Atrium known as The Hub
what's the point of creating such a
flexible multi-use space like this why
not just close it off make it desks fit
more people in I think for you know
Marriott and also for us it was
recognizing that you know the way people
are going to be working it's not
prescriptive we want to give people
choice employees could sit here
here or even work here people really
love these especially on those days when
it's not so nice outside right you're
still gonna walk and talk in X and you
can even do it in high heels if you want
to yeah up one floor before the more
traditional workspaces is this lab-like
space which holds a test kitchen bar and
that mock-up room we've drawn with a
sharpie where the mirror will be where
the TV will be and it's all to give you
a sense of what this room will feel like
and we can move this wall back six
inches and you can actually see that six
inches can make a big difference in
terms of how a hotel room could feel but
to see how guests actually experience a
new room design Marriott will use those
13 guest rooms being built inside the
hotel next door we didn't have this in
our old building we had sample rooms in
a basement right and since it was in a
basement there wasn't natural light
there was fake windows and there wasn't
real plumbing and you certainly couldn't
see a hotel room right there was like a
movie set you could you didn't say
overnight there but now with our new
corporate headquarters we can do things
we never could have done before
sample rooms in the lab space Marriott
has devoted more than 22 000 square feet
of space to Innovation that's balanced
with 16 more traditional Workforce like
this one just upstairs
there are 2842 workspaces most of those
are desks which aren't actually assigned
to employees instead the hotel company
uses the hoteling model what are you
doing in this space to give people some
level of privacy in some sense that they
have ownership over their work and it's
a lot of differential spatial
experiences so you know if you look at
where you and I are now we're in the
open right but we walk a few feet this
direction over here we're in a different
opportunity to pull aside so the best
way to combat the hard parts of the open
Office plan is to give people other
options give them Choice yeah and that's
just what Marriott did when it tweaked
the design during the pandemic
originally the workspace floors looked
like this mostly individual workstations
then 25 of those desks were removed
creating a floor plan that looks like
this with couches tables and booths why
take away that 25 percent of desks and
add these new spaces I think you still
do need in individual workstations and
private space right but much of the work
that's done in the hotel business in the
case of our company is collaboration
Marriott's office opened to employees at
a time when office use is on the rise
nationally workers are returning to
offices at the highest rate since the
pandemic began as coveted infection
numbers fall and companies increasingly
mandate in office time Marriott however
plans to stay hybrid as people start to
come back to the office even in a hybrid
environment I wonder what role office
design has to play in getting them to
come to work more it's a catalyst for
sure I deeply believe that hybrid work
makes a lot of sense and it can be very
successful but hybrid work does mean
that you are part of the time working
physically together when you walk around
if spaces aren't full and people are
working remote or traveling will the
investment in this new office space
still feel worth it because I'm in the
hotel in the travel business I believe
people need to be together other that's
why everyone's traveling again right and
I think that's true in the case of work
as well so I'm very confident that this
building will be full enough of the time
to be well worth the investment
[Music]